two hello everybody welcome to
off the rails with ethan klein without
ela
klein podcast today's episode is
sponsored by magic spoon
and adam and eve quickly guys
teddyfresh.com new collection is out
today
thursday if you're watching on thursday
um we got new beanies
beautiful beanies gorgeous beanies some
of the best beanies ever
gorgeous beanies we got a restock of the
flame hoodie that everyone
loved and pants this is the shirt i'm
wearing now
it's just a good solid shirt really cool
look at that come on now teddy fresh ela
klein ladies and gentlemen got the x-ray
teddy bear
you know you love it this is the kind of
a
split tee with a knitted uh collar you
know you love it
restock on this classic [ __ ] piece
we love it a new camp shirt we love it
keep going
this is the baby the baby famously wore
this piece and it
is super hot fire you know what time it
is teddyfish.com
this is shirt i design which you may or
may not like i don't know but it says
sleep eat work die
love to see it um and
this shirt is the pink version oh we
have a earth day shirt all the profits
go to
um the rain forest uh there's like a
rainforest federation global federation
we're donating all the profits of this
shirt to that
this graphic is awesome i love it earth
day baby you gotta love the earth that's
it head on over to teddyfresh.com to
peep our new collection thank you
now you guys were just telling me about
how good i looked because i was looking
at myself because i had to cut off my
beard
for the mask um
and i look so fat and gross without a
beer
thoughts you're a fat
fat fatty right why are you guys quiet
now you were just telling me how
yeah i i genuinely
thought to myself when you walked out
here that uh that you're looking pretty
good you're looking healthy
when you say healthy that is that are
you saying i look slimmer because when
you say
a little bit slimmer i i think it's the
combination of losing the beard
and you've also um you're also wearing
black which is slimming
okay so not really a compliment i mean
i thought you i thought you looked good
okay thank you dan i thought you looked
other than like the face makeup i
thought you looked very slender that's
what i'm looking for i want
slender i don't want it healthy healthy
means fat in some
in some places you're looking really
unhealthy
slender would be the time yeah but i was
wearing the mask you couldn't even see
my
because i had a chat like the mask was
all chatted out i thought it looked good
with the chad face
big ass chin and stuff i was like yeah
everybody said that you look like a
handsome swidworth yes i know it's true
actually damn
it's crazy but it's true the mask is
kind of hat
which came first massacre handsome
squidward sword
sword i think squidward alright no the
mask came first
interesting well i'll take i'll take
whatever i can get
you know i've been doing good pretty
good though been staying on my
my diet kind of
but i've been exercising i think it
shows no i'm
i'm serious it looks you look slimmer
yeah you're looking good
all right ian you have anything to say
to me
i'm noticing silence from ian
everybody's complimented me uh
crickets over here on ian gladian yeah
you look like a
soundbite you look like a um yeah like a
beautiful
swan that just emerged from its
daddy like a butterfly swan butterfly
you mean like kind of hybrid butterfly
swan
yes butterfly swan skinny skinny
bold beautiful cover girl wow thank you
ian that felt very sincere
we got a lot to talk about today man we
got a whole action-packed episode
oh zach got exposed to covid he's now
he's in like some weird like hospital
curtain situation he looked like you're
in like your grandma's house like
facing their backyard but you had to
close the blinds right right
right yeah where are you right now what
what are these blinds behind you can you
open them
it's uh just like a just a window yeah
yeah i uh half vaccinated and the people
that um
had coveter tested positive were fully
vaccinated
so and they still got it yeah dude
yeah so which vaccine did they get i
believe the pfizer
that's what you get oh no modernity
modernity gang let's go
i'm madonna but i thought pfizer was
bulletproof that was like supposed to be
the rolls royce
that's more i i get according to
statistics that's more like
effective well like my point propaganda
they're all
madurain advisor both like 95 after two
doses but damn they still got it huh
yeah well the good news is even if you
catch it once you've been vaccinated it
reduces the severity
yeah so it's just it's kind of [ __ ]
because this was supposed to be
or next week is you know move-in week
so um wait
yeah you finally you're about to move
into your new place
yeah may 1st yeah oh [ __ ] zach is moving
out of his parents house you guys
is so big i gotta get you a housewarming
present
eventually it's very sweet of you yeah
iron lung
[Laughter]
so it's just kind of bad timing oh i
look i'm sorry but i'm looking
at myself in the screen i'm trying to
sympathize with you zach but i look like
such a [ __ ]
monster oh oh stop
it zach i don't know if i could help you
move by the way now
oh thanks a.b let's let's wait till you
test it first
yeah you were going to help him move
that's a good friend yeah that's not
that's
that's high level friendship right there
moving he wanted to film it he's like
the only movie
oh you just wanted did you say that it
was actually the exact opposite
zack's like we should make a video out
of it sure
well whoa whoa whoa what's the truth
here no he's like we should film it
so amy who said we should film it
i'm legit going through my phone right
now you both are accusing me of
filming it and now actually there's
something interesting going on here
let's see i'm going through my phone i'm
looking for the receipts because zach is
saying you
only would help him if you could film it
[ __ ] you baby
and that is interesting hmm
he's uh going off the stereotype i don't
know what to say he's going off the
clock
stereotype what are you talking about
goblin stereotype i don't know
the clown goblin stereotype wait
what's going on here why are you both
zach
what's going on why is what's happening
here
he offered to help me move which was
very sweet a baby
you know and i said yeah you know that
could be cool he's like yeah we should
film it
i'm like okay yeah so these are not
compatible stories
at all and then abe you're saying zack
is the one why would zach want to film
his movie that seems like something you
would want to do
in defense of zack dude i i'm
i swear zack's the one that that first
set out but
in zack's defense i did agree i did say
yeah it might make a good segment for
the show
to be fair you do make all the behind
the scenes videos so why wouldn't you
want to film it
[Music]
wait wait this is so confusing
do you both sincerely believe that the
other person proposed filming it
yes wow this is this is
bizarro all right find the receiver yeah
we need the receipts you better look
into this
okay i can't make to wait to make a
comment later i've been noticing a lot
of tension lately between
zach and a bean everything okay
no not everything is not okay
me and zach are good he calls me every
monday we have our monday
uh check-in but you guys have a
scheduled like chit-chat call
we'll we'll just you know make sure you
know just you know hi how are you doing
you know
show prep stuff oh it's it's work
related see abe
is trying to make he abby's planting you
like like this is work related ab
it's not like we do we do have a
personal call
this isn't a work related to call it's
not work related
it's big brother advice
to be fair we do discuss work too yeah
of course yeah of course
okay am i paying for this call or no
depends how you look at it he calls me
collect
[Laughter]
uh all right you get you let me know
when you find those receipts i'm really
curious now i want to get to the bond
with this
okay in the meantime
[Applause]
some nice goofs here at the top of the
show before we get into somewhat serious
stuff
you know i always want to talk about
derek chovin going to prison
finally a cop is going to go to jail for
uh killing somebody
and i don't really want to talk about
like all the yada yada's
uh the serious stuff you know what i do
want to talk about
is all these conservatives all these
supposed free thinking conservatives who
somehow have the same exact opinion
about every social
issue almost like they're pandering to
their [ __ ] white supremacist
audience um how
people are not totally happy with this
verdict how the
it's it's crazy like all how can every
conservative talking head
think that this was a misjustice
how how for the world
but anyway they're all having meltdowns
on social media so i thought it'd be fun
to look at them
they're really wild man it's crazy um
there's that
there's a oh my god i hate that this is
like a political
i swear it may seem like a political
episode but it's fun
because the [ __ ] is ridiculous okay you
guys know about the my pillow guy
frank um mike mike
yeah his website is frank
right i love it he apparently made a um
new social media platform to rival
twitter because all
every con every conservative you know
who was just spreading misinformation
about
you know coveted um saying racist [ __ ]
you know
we're getting banned off twitter oh god
you know how hard it is to get banned on
twitter yeah
you could say some really violent [ __ ]
on twitter isis has a twitter account
they're still up
well i don't think anymore they call
them dumb they did that i'm kidding i'm
kidding
they did though they did
for a good while there isis is more
brand friendly than uh
some of these conservatives so anyway
the my pillow guy is on a quest to ruin
his life
he made a billion dollars selling
pillows and now he's doing a speed race
to see how long he can uh
lose it all and his social media is
called frank speech
and there's it's all about free speech
except one uh
caveat of course you cannot take the
lord's name in vain
so as we know free speech doesn't have
any limits of course unless it
offends my sensibility
also no f word no f word
naughty naughty
naughty naughty naughty
[Music]
um you could say the f word here all you
want just not in the first 30.
snoop what do you think about no f word
so anyway um
it's a total disaster it's hilarious he
thinks trump is calling in and it's a
prank caller
it's just the whole thing is amazing
he's being sued for 1.3 billion dollars
by dominion
i mean the whole thing is just fantastic
uh we've got this and a bunch of other
stuff you know
oh do we have receipts we do have
receipts see
okay let's get to the bottom of it let's
get to the bottom of
it here i'll read it so here it is it
says
now i'm free to help you move i don't
know if i offered already said ab
zach responds i appreciate it man i
might take you up on that
we should film it crying laffy emoji
[ __ ] get out zach
okay it originated because and i'm gonna
look through our conversations because
it might be
a little further down but um we were
having one of these monday calls and
he's like
um yeah we should totally film it
so he he implied it first what the [ __ ]
very convenient that he implied it in a
place where there can be no
record kept of it very convenient
well hold on hold on hold on a b do you
recall what zack saying
no but i didn't feel you're so full of
[ __ ] i did feel bad outing him because
i'm going through my act
i'm going through our text messages i'm
seeing how much he offered if i need
help on anything and i felt bad outing
him but
i want to equip myself we gotta get to
the bottom of this because like you said
you do have a clout goblin reputation
and i do feel that zack this contradicts
your story you know
you're clearly up for the filming which
is fine i'm not i'm just trying to get
to the bottom of what's going on here
i i know i'm i'm i'm up for the filming
but he presented the idea first
this contradicts that say that well you
know i mean
so he said you're according to you he
said oh we should film it
but then you brought it up like because
you're bringing it up like first for the
first time you say we should film it
it's not like oh it seems that way
you know what i mean like he brought it
up first okay
yeah that that that's my defense makes
perfect sense to me
all right that sounds sounds legit i
mean to be fair abe
i mean like you said i love you abe he
is the clown goblin he does run the
behind the scenes stuff you know i i
don't even know
but he's cool you know he's not like
thank you trisha here zach does not own
a camera
now i'm not accusing anyone of being a
clown goblin i just want to know what's
going on here
it was a b okay wow please ethan you
have to trust me on this one
i mean okay if you can i mean listen i i
i'm a man of
facts and evidence my my next message is
yeah it could be good i mean
well that sounds like so let me ask you
guys this are we still going to film it
well now i don't know yeah because of
the velvet well no now i'm just kind of
turned off the whole idea
right so well it's your idea where was
this
it's not my idea i mean it okay
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna try and if this
was in a courtroom
this is very damning evidence zach
so you guys stereotyped me you
stereotyped me for being a clown goblin
you guys thought i was guilty well to be
fair you don't have the best track
record
but hold on zach you weak
i need that clout zach you said we
should film it
i okay i did say that but he had the
idea first
all right where was this content going
to live on the podcast or like on tick
tock or on aby's channel where were we
gonna put this
i have no idea do you think that the
podcast audience wants to watch you move
zack
no
maybe how is that behind the scenes for
the podcast zach moving
i am this is abey's idea this isn't my
idea
i'm going to try and find the tag what's
the i mean i love to watch a time lapse
of you guys picking up the moving boxes
i mean even though it was zack's idea i
thought it was oh for [ __ ] sake
potentially as a short segment since
we're always goofing on him for living
at home
right that's true it is a big moment for
zach
how your parents feel about you moving
out are they proud of you uh yeah they
are
that's good they should be yeah it's
awesome man you're supporting yourself
that's huge
yeah it's uh you know they're a little
sad but um
sad you're grown as a man they should be
begging you for you to leave
i wish that was the case but somebody
they want you to live in a house forever
it's time for you to [ __ ] spread your
wings and fly
they're always like you can live with us
till you're 50. weirdos yeah
pants are weird peace and love yeah so
i don't know they're just they're a
little sad but they're being supportive
so that's sweet that's good yeah they're
sweet
we love that shout out to todd and
what's your mom's name
stacy todd and stacy
all right well let's get to the content
all right zach if you have any evidence
to refute this
let me know i'm all yours but absolutely
yeah i'm looking forward to it
so trump um
apparently he's still confused he thinks
he's president he's still giving out
lifetime achievement awards
and he gave one to walk a flock of flame
i will say that while
waka wakka does seem like a good guy so
i'm like cool
with this but
this president award not only do he
deserve it
why today thank you
he's so humble it's scary he is waka is
a very humble
[ __ ] is trump in a position to be
giving out like awards and stuff now i
mean he's not the president
i mean i guess
he has like maybe a foundation or
something
lifetime achievement award on behalf of
what's leaving on the dredge
like trump's just giving out lifetime
achievement he's got the minute he's got
the presidential seal on him yeah
he's real he's just cosplaying president
he's just he can't get over the fact
that he's not president
he's still giving out presidential
medals
president trump's recognizing me thank
bridget uh
just think everybody loves me just
enough to love you back
anyway we're proud of waka because he
does deserve it apparently he's been
doing a lot of great
uh work but what's funny
um here it says the pr
look at this medal it says the
president's volunteer service award i'm
sorry what
maybe it was already in motion before he
left office
and so do you think so i mean maybe i i
don't know it
i agree it's weird though oh yeah you're
right it says we're told 45 signed and
certified the trump administration had
everything approved before trump
oh there you go so it's an official uh
presidential medal that's great i mean
i'm proud of the guy
he is this kind of surprised us he's a
doctor
yeah that's really cool to you doctor
he has an honorary phd in philosophy and
humanities or something right
humanitarianism
humanitarianism was that a discipline
well when it's an honorary degree i
think you can kind of fudge what it's
for a little bit
i i'm a doctorate and getting [ __ ]
i have an honorary doctorate's degree
and getting smashing
ass i'm gonna come
so anyway um shout out to dr walker
flock of flame
we love that about him and there's
actually it's just there's a whole
you know um waka was one of the subjects
of my first
video edits this is from 2013 man [ __ ]
2013 bro are you kidding me
eight years ago eh it's rewind time
this is the kind of [ __ ] i was up to
back in the day if you guys are curious
what yeah
you know back in the day my whole thing
was i was just making this video edits i
was never on camera
and i kept making these video edits like
this and they were getting lots of views
like millions of views
but nobody was subscribing to my channel
and i was like what the [ __ ] why does
nobody
why is nobody want to [ __ ] subscribe
to my [ __ ] and so i realized that it's
because
they're not connecting with me it's just
a video edit nobody cares it's kind of
video people just watch and move on like
they have no reason to come and watch my
channel
yep and that's when i pivoted to making
reaction videos because i was making a
ton of these video edits
they were getting lots of views nobody
gave a [ __ ] about me
so i was like god damn i should make
different kind of content so
that's when i made my first reaction and
the rest is history
um so you have waka the
waka to thank for all this waka
definitely one of my early my early
grades cover all 9
000 tastebuds this video has 14 million
views
and i i never thought i would make a
video that would get more views than
this
back in the day i think it had like 5
million when i started making reaction
videos and i was like
it's kind of sad knowing that i'll never
make a video they'll get more views than
this one but anyway that's fun you know
what i mean
warm it up but yeah it's not even close
to number one
get that taco that cream pure vanilla
sweeteners
that's a 10. were you monetized at the
time
no no i don't even think there was
monetization when i made this [ __ ]
2013. this guy's such a legend he's a
professional ice cream taster
and he has his tongue insured for a
million dollars he makes a big point
about saying that
and he uses a golden spoon can you guys
find clips of him there's a bunch of
clips of him and i always enjoy watching
um yeah i love this guy
there's there's so many of these dude
like here little bit
painsley area exe a couple
of teaspoons of sugar just give that a
really good mix there
mix that in
this is one people really enjoyed
[Music]
that's it
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
that's it
to be honest with you guys
i had oh this one got age restricted oh
it's because it has dj
khaled having sex that sucks that was
one of my favorites the khalid one
to be honest with you guys i didn't know
what the [ __ ] i was doing so if you ever
want to make videos you don't have to
like i literally learned how to edit
making this this was the first video i
ever
edited here's one called pickles i
didn't remember what the [ __ ] this is
oh yeah this guy i just i couldn't get
over
he says what's one thing you wouldn't
want police to find in the trunk of your
car and he says pickles
i was like what so i made this whole
video just on my thumbnail
in the trunk of your car pickles
[Music]
god it's so stupid so this is a some of
those are so
dumb that's okay that's what it's all
about right
um it's rewind time oh here
speaking of waka here's another wakka
clip that i think is worth watching as
we're at the top of the show here
again i think wakka's the best and this
proves it we love walking here on this
show
apparently this is some comedian oh my
god bro this is
really bad oh my god
[Applause]
the worst thing you've ever seen in your
life
is she famous do people know who that is
i don't oh man i'm looking it up now
and i'm seeing waka saying that we set
that up we staged that
oh no why'd you say that you should have
kept that to yourself
they staged that well who's the girl
i'm not saying her name in here huh
interesting he's a liar he's a doctor
i thought he was a doctor but actually
he's just a liar damn
fake doctor oh man
i was so invested in this being real oh
here it says comedian kate
quigley so anyway before we move on i
wanted to
show you guys the ice cream guy he's one
of my favorite people in the world
here's a little hi a little bit of him
eating ice
fat frozen yogurts the cholesterol
freeze he's doing a
blind taste test to prove that his taste
buds are superior and of course he gets
every single one right ratio between
premium ice creams and then the low fats
wow well now we want to we want to test
we've got different kinds of ice creams
tastes good one of them is
ice cream okay and and looking for is an
ice cream taster uh dave is uh
kind of uh two words when it comes to
body and texture
can you see that spoon he's got a gold
spoon there i take it right off the top
because that's the warmest and then
invert it cover my taste bud
roll it around bring the aroma back to
the nose the top note
that fine balance between the cream the
dairy in other words
the sugar sweeteners and that pure
vanilla
is that the way we should be eating this
well uh it's all right
okay you know some people like to stir
it up um in their bowl
oh that's good that's good now roll
around
all right i feel like taster doesn't
host is making a mockery of the his
art he's not taking it he's using a
plastic spoon he's trying to make a joke
about him trying to get all goofy he
lets it dribble out of his mouth i just
i'm not charmed by you dude
it's disrespectful as [ __ ] oh it's
already gone
it's not necessary to swallow to taste
but we're gonna do it here
okay that's good all right good moves
now
that one yeah so anyway i think he's for
real if you were that was a
typical uh more refreshing uh a little
cooler
uh 1991 do you think he's still doing
this okay still kicking let's go to the
next problem
just keep doing it man just keep tasting
ice cream
you know what i mean what you got better
[ __ ] to do than taste ice cream i mean
people like semen we don't know maybe he
suffered a career-ending uh injury to
his tongue
i wonder if he eats a girl if he's like
no eating out
i cannot risk straining my tongue
and for anything he doesn't eat out you
said he insured his tongue for a million
dollars right
yeah maybe he had a [ __ ]
to cash out i wonder if eating
a girl out is like super intense for him
because you've got these extraordinary
tasting skills
apparently he tastes an average of 60
ice cream flavors on a daily basis
he did not consume the ice cream he spit
it out that's disgusting he had a spit
cup full of
ice cream spit tastes like semen
anyway tasting that much ice cream every
day didn't
i'd eat it well i'd have a [ __ ]
mobility scooter and i'd scoot around
the factory and i would eat the
well ice cream reason you don't get paid
to eat ice cream and he does derek
shovin finally went to prison what
we're we're just about a 30 minute mark
so we should probably go to break oh
really
yeah all right we'll throw it to break
and we'll come back and talk about that
peace
and love peace and love
magic's boom god
i am obsessed with magic spoon
i have always loved cereal but it's hard
to get away with eating cereal these
days
as an adult who's trying not to be
morbidly obese
because you know good cereals packed
with sugar
and junk and carbs that's why magic
spoon
is changed the game forever
zero grams of sugar 14 grams of protein
and only four net grams of carbs in each
serving
it only has 140 calories per serving
it's incredible it's made from like milk
protein blend
so it doesn't have any flour in it
um and it's all protein
it tastes so good that's where i got it
this is a game changer
i know you guys don't like me eating the
mic but they asked me to eat it
for the copyright i was like sure
[ __ ] thing
bro they got four flavors
big best-selling flavors the cocoa
fruity frosted and peanut butter
they're all amazing dude i have been
kicking down this magic spoon i'm
telling you it is a game changer
[ __ ] this is the frost one i love the
fruity i love the coconut
i'll be honest i don't like the peanut
butter flavors
but the cocoa fruity and frosted wow
top level [ __ ] i
honestly taste exactly like the cereal
you had growing up except
it's healthy it's not going to make you
fat
it tastes amazing and honestly i feel
like it's too good to be true
it's keto friendly goo gluten free grain
free
soy free low carb and
gmo free
i'm telling you just try this [ __ ] the
high protein
keto friendly gluten-free grain-free
soy-free wheat-free naturally flavored
totally delicious child like cereal for
products
whoa well it's not big connect
it's real okay that's real
it is real yo
trust me when i say you have to try
magic spoon
click the link below and grab a variety
pack try it today
and be sure to use the promo code h3 at
checkout and get five dollars off your
order
go to magicspoon.com
h3 magic spoon is so confident that with
their product is backed by a 100
happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund you no questions asked
click the link below and use code h3 for
five dollars off or go to magicspoon.com
h3 to save five dollars today
derrick shelvin is a piece of [ __ ] cop
who got went to jail for murdering
george floyd
and of course there was the predictable
conservative meltdown because first of
all these people were like so excited
for rioting to take place
they were so ready for the like country
to burn down just so they could like
drive home all of their their white
nationalist points you know
well they also they were so upset that
there weren't riots everywhere
right and i think that just goes to show
that they were all
fully expecting him to get off yeah
right i was too to be honest you know
because they always do they always do
they usually do i i i felt like he was
he was [ __ ] well listen if you can't
convict a guy who kneeled on someone's
neck for nine minutes and was filmed the
whole time doing it
if that's not enough evidence then
there's never enough evidence to convict
anyone for anything
any police officer for anything but they
did it they convicted him
guilty on all counts and they handcuffed
that [ __ ] and they stumped him
off the jail it was quite a sight
here he is he looks kind of confused the
whole time in the court they were just
like
he just looked kind of confused like
what police sellers aren't supposed to
go to jail for killing people that's
what we do that's why i signed up
i did feel like because i i actually saw
a range of interpretations of like his
facial expressions and everything and i
i feel like there's a little bit of like
a
rorschach test effect going on
especially since he had a mask on
because i saw some people saying that he
looked confused others
looking like he had no emotion at all
other people saying that he
uh looked like he was about to cry i
think he honestly i think he was just
shocked
i think he was just in like a surreal
state of shock
he's sitting there about to go to jail
for like probably life you know 75 years
in prison he's
he's facing i mean the dude was a cop
like i think that most he's facing 40.
and so at his age it's like a life
sentence you know what i mean yeah i
mean effectively
any and jail ain't going to be easy on a
cop
who killed somebody you know he'll be in
protective
custody yeah but the entire time yeah
but you know what i'm saying you pass
people in the hallway and [ __ ] it's it's
not going to be a happy experience for
him
probably not so i think for him he's
just in a state of shock it's just
surreal you
you're out one day a cop pushing
everyone i mean this was not a good cop
this guy had a history of like um
a violent of being a violent cop and so
he's on one hand he goes from being on
the street being the top dog that can
has power over everyone to go into
[ __ ] jail you know
so i think his whole world is just
upside down i don't know
yeah anyway um he's in prison
and this was i didn't really understand
this but he's found guilty of like
second-degree manslaughter third degree
murder
and second degree murder i i was like i
don't know you could
be found guilty on three different
charges of killing someone
oh abe said he so this [ __ ] guy by
the way you know how the conservatives
always go oh george
george floyd ran a stop sign when he was
15
so you know he kind of had it coming
right like whenever anything like this
happens they always assassinate the
character of the victim
always but why do none of them mention
that this cop derek chauvin
had 18 complaints on his official record
18 complaints two of which ended in
discipline
including official letters of reprimand
nobody [ __ ] mentions this guy this
this cop is apparently a true patriot
and every cop should be
um should be quitting
in solidarity with him this guy had
18 complaints on his record why does no
one bring that up this guy is not a good
cop
he's a piece of [ __ ] 18 complaints in
only 19 years
so it's like once a year
every year i mean the guy had an
official reprimand he was disciplined
twice i mean
there's way too much patience in the
system for bad cops
you could look at this guy and be like
this guy is a bad cop so why the [ __ ]
was he allowed to stay on
i'm supposed to worry about george floyd
because like
he did drugs yeah this guy beats the
[ __ ] out of people for a living
and calls it justice anyway
he's in jail these were the these are
the counts he says
uh second-degree manslaughter uh
i'm kind of i was just interested in the
charges let's see
secondary manslaughter is when a person
creates an unreasonable risk and
consciously takes the chance of causing
death or great bodily harm to someone
else i mean yeah that
that boom easy easy conviction
he was guilty he was guilty on that and
then there was a
third degree murder third degree murder
is unintentionally causing someone's
death by committing an act that is
eminently dangerous to other persons
while exhibiting
while exhibiting a depraved mind
with reckless disregard for human life
wow
this is interesting because i'm not
familiar with like all these degrees of
murder
third degree murder guilty
it varies from state to state too by the
way so these are the definitions in uh
minneapolis minnesota second-degree
murder
second-degree murder is causing the
death of a human being without intent to
cause that death while committing or
attempting to commit another felony
oh in this case the alleged felony was
third degree assault
interesting so they also found them
guilty on that
so what is first-degree murder just
pre-meditated straight-up murder
yes you have to have intent
beforehand you're like i'm gonna go kill
this dude right it's not it's not a
it's not it's not a heat of the moment
kind of thing it's it's you you
set out with the intent of killing
someone oh they got him good man on all
this [ __ ]
guilty on all charges yeah i was reading
this morning that i guess in uh
minnesota typically um the time is
served concurrently
so that's why yeah the 40 is is likely
the max he'll see
yeah i think he'll serve exactly
but i think it's just for the record you
know like yep so anyway
what i really was not couldn't get
enough of
yesterday was the you know conservative
uh meltdown
ben all the usual suspects
what i i've blown away that all these
so-called free-thinking conservatives
right have the same take on every issue
how is it possible that not
one of them ever deviates and has a
[ __ ] original thought in their head
if they're such free thinkers
how is it that all of them agree that
somehow this
cop who was filmed for nine minutes
killing this man
what is a miscarriage of justice not one
of them thinks it's a reasonable thing
okay
ben shapiro of course
[Applause]
the biggest brain on the right wet ass
p word the the uh
the most galaxy brained of them all
[Music]
uh don lemon said justice has been
served
and ben's like oh no i'm going in
justice has been served
i'm going in he said and we all know
we would never have said this if the
reverse verdict had been reached
how was that [ __ ] insightful
[Laughter]
hassan ratio the [ __ ] out of him was
epic hassan
a friend of the show 176 000 likes
swoops in
he says almost like there's a difference
between a murderer going free and not i
mean yeah what is your point ben like
literally you're [ __ ] that's an
insightful tweet
if this hypothetical thing that didn't
happen there's some horrors in this
house
this hypothetical thing had happened
instead of what actually happened then
you all know you'd be acting differently
well that's like
that's the whole point is that yes that
that would not be justice
if a murderer walked free yes that would
not be justice ben
very [ __ ] insightful extra large and
extra hard
literally i don't even understand the
point of his statement i mean
i'll say what i think he's saying is
that
if the verdict had been not guilty
and it was determined that he hadn't
killed george floyd in a hypothetical
world where there was some circumstance
that
could explain away why he didn't kill
him
and that it was proven to be not guilty
we wouldn't nobody would be saying oh
justice has been served yeah
exactly exactly that's the whole point
of this whole movement
that would be not justice dumb [ __ ]
i think what he's saying is like oh you
have to accept the court's decision
no again i think he's he's trying to we
don't need to analyze ben shapiro's
dumbass tweet wet ass p word
yeah ben got clowned on a lot for that
one i've that was a really epic uh ratio
by hassan so definitely
a shout out to hassan tim poole which
again
is another usual suspect it's like they
all have the same [ __ ] take
tim poole man this guy is kind of the
worst
he's one of these guys that pretends he
used to be like a democrat
and then woke politics somehow pushed
him to the right isn't that his whole
check yeah
that's why he tweeted cops need to
resign and mass
now really
i have no problem with a cop resigning
in
response to one of their [ __ ]
look you got a bad apple right we keep
talking about bad apples in the police
fort
if you're an officer that has a problem
with derrick shoven going to prison then
i would [ __ ] happily accept your
resignation
right and i'd be glad to replace you
with someone new
i love how tim pool is just speaking on
behalf of all cops by the way
all cops need to resign now and mass
it's like okay tim
behind your [ __ ] computer
sitting at home like dude
[Music]
so not only is he saying that derek was
wrongfully convicted
he's taken upon himself to insist that
all cops now must
resign in solidarity with their
in solidarity with their murderous
brother
he wants no police on the street do you
want police on the street or not tim you
know what i mean
i know people were clowning on him like
hey that's kind of based
yeah abolish the police exactly exactly
these guys are they literally can't even
keep track of their own [ __ ] points
because oh it's really the top reply
based by accident
based by accident yeah you know because
tim is like because
there's this whole movement abolish the
police right and so
all people like tim pool are always
going what do people think they're just
going to be police there's going to be
nobody to stop them
there's going to be crime there's going
to be murders right and so now all of a
sudden
when one cop finally one cop
finally gets held to account
because there's actually just a video in
his face of it happening
which disputes by the way his official
report i read the official report can
you find that i was tweeted by um
anderson
cooper i think the official report of
that day before the video was released
said something like there was an
altercation with a man
who died of a drug overdose no
weapons were fired that was the official
police report
what the [ __ ] you know and that's how
they [ __ ] cover this [ __ ] up
every time but now there's a camera in
his face and he actually gets held
accountable and people like tim poole
are like we all all cops need to resign
here i found it you want me to send it
to you or read it uh
you can send it to me okay
yeah you guys wanna know how crazy we
love dan you guys know how crooked this
[ __ ] is okay
this is the police report of george
floyd being murdered by derek chauvin
before the video was released are you
ready for this
okay man dies after medical incident
during police interaction
it's an interaction it's a nice way to
say murder
i had a i had an interaction
on monday evening shortly after 8 pm
officers from minneapolis police
department responded to a
3700 block of chicago avenue south on a
report of forgery in progress
officers were advised that the suspect
was sitting on top of a blue car and
appeared to be under the influence
two officers arrived and located the
suspect a male believed to be in his 40s
in his car
he was ordered to step from his car
after he got out he physically resisted
officers
officers were able to get the suspect
into handcuffs and noted he appeared to
be suffering
medical distress officers called for an
ambulance he was transported to um
hennepin county medical center by
ambulance where he died shortly after
there were no at no time were weapons of
any used
weapons of any type used by anyone
involved in the incident
so this is how they write up a
cold-blooded [ __ ] murder
in front of two of his colleagues right
they said so remember he had his net his
knee
dug into his neck as he begged for his
life he said i can't breathe
nine minutes a murder and they describe
that as
officers got him into handcuffs and
noted he was suffering medical distress
they called him an ambulance where he
died shortly after
and tim paul is defending the system all
cops need to resign
bye
bye
that's what we're saying we finally
agreed timpool
these guys are such grifters bro i swear
to [ __ ] god they don't even care
they have no opinion they have no
original thought they're all just
spewing the same
vile [ __ ] that they know their their
white supremacist
by the way this is white supremacy let's
be real this [ __ ] cops
have they have a blank check to
kill i mean dude this is white supremacy
i mean this is it right i mean this is
like
lightly veiled white supremacy
this [ __ ] happens all the time
especially to black men and i mean
happens
black black people you know
i can't believe this [ __ ] and so there's
like a whole
mass of like right wing ultra
right-wingers that consume content on
youtube and
popular media because i guess fox news
isn't racist enough for them
and so um they're they're just giving
them what they want i don't think tim
poole i don't even know what he really
agrees but he's just making money
because they get tons of [ __ ] views
on youtube
and they ha they can't deviate because
the their their fans revolt
you know yeah uh as a matter of fact did
you see
uh well i think her name's janine
pirro or something judge pirro or
whatever she's like the legal expert on
fox news all the time
she's a died in the wool conservative
and you know big time trump supporter
you know as as right wing as you'd think
that they come
and after the trial i mean she said
the truth which is that this there the
prosecution's case is solid
it won't be overturned in appeal i know
people don't want to hear that
but she actually you know said it like
it is
and the audience is now stopping her
like they're
you know the the anti-cancel culture mob
is now trying to
cancel her because she didn't toe the
line that's it i
don't like it i love that because that's
so true it's so obvious right
everybody's there to get this specific
take they want to validate their own
their own belief and so when someone
there
is brave enough to actually [ __ ] say
what they think that goes against the
grain
they get castrated by these by these
rabid people that they've all kind of
[ __ ] kind of have to own at this
point
by just spoon feeding them toxic mania
and that's how you end up in this
situation
so they're trying to cancel her for just
saying that the prosecution is i mean
this just happened yesterday i mean i
don't
you know these people have the attention
spans of goldfish so
they'll be but yeah you'll be pissed off
at something else probably by now so
you know if tim poole made a video being
like the honestly
if it was just like derek chauvin goes
to prison and it was the right decision
it would have like 80
dislikes i'm unsubbing
tim's lost it he's always been a liberal
right stephen crowder of course who
um made a youtube video i don't know if
you guys saw it where he
did we ever sh i don't think we do i
don't think we did it's pretty
[ __ ] up can we pull up a clip of that
list well i i think he actually
got removed and i think that's what
actually tipped it over the
uh he he's like suspended from youtube
now and i think he lost his conversation
like permanently
so this [ __ ] i probably shouldn't
show it
this actual steaming pile of dog [ __ ]
named stephen crowder did a video
of like a week ago during the trial
where he was like i'm gonna prove to you
guys that there's no way george floyd
died from having a knee
in his neck and he goes outside and he
has his friend put it
put his knee
right he wait whoa whoa okay let me he
was temporary banned for something
because oh he was doing this bla he was
oh my god
he is such a racist he did this video
like making all these black stereotypes
that was super offensive
so he got a temporary ban and his first
video back after his temporary ban
is this video about how george flake
couldn't have died this way
so he goes outside he has his friend
neal on his neck
for 11 or 9 minutes but
like it's he's such a [ __ ]
his friend puts all of his weight on his
back
and he's not jabbing his knee into his
neck
it's just it's so not a fair comparison
and it and i couldn't believe that he
actually made this video and he's such a
[ __ ]
for not actually doing it the right way
he's obviously scared of taking a real
knee in the neck yeah the guy put
the his knee on his back not on his neck
he didn't actually put the pressure on
his neck and also
it didn't do it on blacktop like how it
actually occurred
and the guy on top of him didn't have a
bunch of equipment like a police officer
does
like well all of those things and like
his knee
his like when you look at derek his knee
is jagged
slamming into his neck this guy was on
his like kneecaps
his pressure wasn't like slamming into
his neck
like a jagged you know what i mean yeah
i'm going to send you a picture right
now that you can put up
yeah exactly the original video is gone
i was just trying to find it it's gone
but so you see how he's on his neck
hey i mean he's not actually he's trying
to do something look at this
[ __ ] if you're gonna [ __ ] do it you
might as well
do it this is really you are such a
[ __ ]
and again the reason that they did this
is because of uh
when in the body cam footage which is
separate from the video that most people
saw
it parts of the body cam footage it kind
of looks like
that's what's happening but it's a very
distorted angle obviously super wide
angle lens
on the person's chest or whatever and
from every other angle you can see
what's actually going on and they
covered this in the trial and it was
thoroughly debunked so
i mean if he was actually watching the
trial yeah i mean yeah i don't think any
of these guys watch the trial i don't
think because all the moments
from the trial the prosecution was
amazing
wow that's and that's why i was saying
earlier i
i really didn't think he was going to
get off because if you were paying
attention to trial at all i mean their
case was
locked up i mean yeah the the
prosecutors were amazing the defense had
like
i mean no [ __ ] case they spent they
spent like
hours arguing talking about how he must
have consumed carbon monoxide from the
exhaust of the car
he goes and then the pro the the
prosecutor gets up and
counter uh he he cross-examines their
medical expert and he goes
do you even know if the car was on or
not he goes no i don't know if the car
was on or not
he goes do you have any way of measuring
co2 in his blood he says no i don't have
any way of measuring that
yeah they were i mean there was because
there was no defense so they were
grasping at straws yeah i mean that
that's what defense lawyers do and you
know no i know hey
it's fine they're doing their job i get
it but um i don't think they watched
because you hear all the talking points
right like oh co2 oh
drugs oh this and that but like if you
actually watch the trial and all the
facts come out
you find out it's all [ __ ]
but is stephen crowder a racist yes
yes
and as he he said by the way i didn't
even read it of course so
he quotes tweet martin luther king jr
martin luther king the third you really
want to come out martin luth the martin
luther king's
okay stephen crowder today justice was
served for the floyd family but we still
live in a nation
clothed in injustice true justice for
black americans can only come through a
complete revolution of values we need an
overhaul of system deeply looted in
racism i agree
steven crowder come in with a hot take
here we go of course there will be a
pivot expect more police to quit in the
coming weeks what the [ __ ]
a pivot what does he mean a pivot like
oh and it's not about george floyd
anymore it's about like uh
you know a wider problem trying to
trying to fix our policing system yeah
that's new nobody ever said that before
it is
of course there would be a pivot to
actually trying to make an actual
difference in the world
[ __ ] predictable liberals trying to
make good meaningful changes
and again these guys are threatening
basically that the police are going to
quit it's like you don't
have you don't speak for the police you
don't [ __ ]
it's these guys are just trying to sell
fear and hysteria
expect more police to quit in the coming
weeks good
right like you said any police officer
that quits over this
that's a blessing that's great it's
fantastic it's great news
fantastic he goes yo i'm really
unsettled that i can't go kill people
right now we don't want those people
being police please
resign uh yeah i had an incident the
official report
we had an incident a medical incident
after a slight altercation no weapons
were used
crowd is like cool that's that's a
perfect description
so mask off on all these pieces of [ __ ]
racists [ __ ] you steven crowder you're a
piece of [ __ ]
you literally are
a [ __ ] white nationalist
i really do think so
you know they can deny being racist all
they want be like ooh
h3 said that i'm a racist can you
[ __ ] believe that
yes this is this is lightly veiled
racism
stephen crowder as a racist has changed
my mind right
exactly well i i once i had a friend in
fifth grade that was black
hmm
yeah changed my mind stephen crowder
well he is like the quarter rings hero
so i think that's he is
yeah the quartering went on the show and
he was like totally fangirling
sounds more nervous than i did the first
time i was on this show
does steven know he pees in his basement
i don't know
that's kind of cocky behavior i don't i
don't think stephen crowder
uh stands for cocky baby or like the
cornering displays
on a daily basis pete in my basement
i saw crowder's last video was uh
yet another uh debate on college campus
video or whatever
i just looked it up this dude's 33 same
age as me i can you imagine
well going to a school and just trying
to argue with a bunch of children why
are you going to college campuses these
kids are not
highly educated i mean they're getting
that's why that's why
i know but like he go he goes and he
asks like random college kids to debate
like uh
you know really complex topics like what
was the reason why he
he asked them to debate let's see it's
like i would love to see you debate
like as a doctor someone with a doctor
yeah anybody that actually knows
what they're talking about you know
opposing voter id
is racist changed my mind yeah latest
yeah why don't you go [ __ ] talk to
like a voting right lawyer
i mean look at this guy wake up you know
i mean dude he's [ __ ] it's so stupid
i wish one of the professors would come
down and debate he probably cut it to be
honest
yeah and that's the exactly you you see
what he wants you to see
yeah he spends all day there and then he
adds and all the all the people that
uh can't argue coherently
man he's such a douche
so that's crowder and then this one's my
favorite one of my favorites
tucker carlson on fox news has been
absolutely having a meltdown
you know he's got complete joker brain
yeah tucker's been
kind of losing it because even even like
a week ago he did this whole
rant on a show about white uh
replacement theory
i was like whoa tucker's like he's been
masked off for a couple years now he's
uh yeah even the white replacement
theory was kind of surprising for me
though
so he is like fully masked off white
supremacist
and of course uh candace owen every
white supremacist
token black person i'm sorry but uh i
don't know how else to put that
she's kind of just the worst
can i say that dan yeah i can say that i
mean that's completely what she is for
conservatives that's 100 accurate i mean
i i i don't know if
it's my right to call her a token black
but
she's correct i mean listen to what she
says here candace owen
is i mean yeah she's the darling of all
these white supremacists because she
just comes out and sells the same [ __ ]
they do and
they could be like look a black person
believes that candace uh hitler wasn't
so bad owens
right
hannah or candice uh hit lick is listen
we needed a final plan owens
final solution final solution not
everything is about hitler
true anyway listen to this great uh
interaction
you'd think in a country like ours
very top i mean this is the most first
world country that's ever been you think
the most civilized
and the most just here you have to
consider a murder case
through the lens of politics when you
get to that point haven't you
already given up civilization why can't
they just admit the trial was fair why
are they obsessed with this idea that
the whole thing was just politicized and
that's the only reason he's found guilty
did anyone actually watch the [ __ ]
trial the guy had no
chance he was caught murdering someone
for nine minutes on video
he has 18 miscon he has 18 complaints
on his record you know
this is not a good dude that's correct
and what we're really seeing is mob
justice and and that's really what
happened with this entire trial this was
not a trial about george floyd or derek
chovin
this was a trial about whether the media
was powerful enough to create a
simulation and decide upon a narrative
absent any facts
whether it was powerful enough to repeat
showing and talking about
a nine minute clip that came from
somebody's cell phone without adding any
contacts without showing the full
you know there was a ton of added
contacts yeah in the trial
nine minutes that's a long video of
additional content i like how she says
it came from a cell phone as somehow
it's like oh it just came from
somebody's cell phone it's like uh
yeah what's wrong with that
god cell phones are great these days bro
full police video which they could have
released they refused to release the
full body cam which would have added
more clarity
to the fact that the media was lying you
know the media came out let's not forget
this tucker the media came out and told
us
that this was a man who was just getting
his life together he was a good
you know good member of society and he
got mixed up because a
racist white police officer had it out
for him and and killed him
now candace owen wright when after the
murder came out she made this whole
long video she was one of the first
people to be like
okay george floyd i'm gonna come out and
tell you about what a terrible person
george floyd was she was doing the
the predictable assassinate the
character of anyone who gets brutalized
by the police
because if he's done anything wrong
previously previous to his arrest it
justifies him being murdered
she goes oh he did a gay porn once oh
well he's a drug user
oh well this he oh he did a robbery back
and such and such and it's like
none of this has anything to do with the
fact
that he was [ __ ] murdered by the
police right
she uh yeah she's basically
she's such a pawn man it's crazy all of
that fell apart
all the facts came out and all of that
fell apart we now know of course
that he had enough fentanyl in him it
was three times the lethal dosage
three times and then when he died but
nobody cares because the media was
successful
and putting out a narrative so that's a
blatant lie and this is [ __ ]
brain poison people that consume this
are literally poisoning their brain
because she's just straight up [ __ ]
lying
it doesn't there need to be some
accountability on like a news broadcast
you can't just
blatantly [ __ ] lie say they had three
times the
three times the what they can because
they they
it's not news this is the argument that
they make over and over again when
that stands they're not news yeah it's
an opinion show it's not news
and oftentimes in court um similar to
the alex jones case we were talking
about recently
um with his whole sandy hook uh
thing is that they're forced in court to
argue themselves that nobody should take
their own show seriously right that's
that that's how they well who's getting
away about themselves was a tucker or
someone
uh i was gonna say that tucker said that
uh off the top of my head uh
it could have been he got sued by
someone he was like oh it's just an act
nobody's supposed to take me seriously
yeah and and i know for sure that was
the alex jones defense is that it's
it's all uh schtick you're honest
performance art your honor
it's all shtick it's not funny so when
you
said that he had three times the amount
of fentanyl that would kill a normal
person
was that schtick just stick your honor
was it true no your honor just stick and
putting out a narrative
and they kept hitting that narrative and
the reason why the democrats are happy
is because they realize of course
the media supports them and now the
democrats how is this a political issue
what they want because they can create a
narrative and then they can treat people
like pawns and get them to basically say
if we don't get what we want we will
riot we will loot
we will send these people out like
soldiers to destroy your
neighborhoods and that is exactly what
has happened that has been the
determination
of this trial the media and the
democrats now have enough power cut to
writing that's not happening
i mean this is propaganda this is brain
[ __ ] poison they're cutting to riding
that isn't happening
this child the media and the there's no
rioting
power to bully to bully and to lie to
you has the date on it again
successfully but very
yeah juxtaposing these images absolutely
so she says
this [ __ ] liar real quick just before
we move on i found it um in
uh us district judge
uh opinion um
the arguments from fox lawyers are that
the general tenor of the show
should then inform the viewer that
carlson is not stating actual facts
about the topics he discusses and in
instead engaging in an exaggeration and
non-literal
commentary see that should not hold up
in court that's just not what he's doing
it's just not this fox persuasively
argues that given mr carlson's
reputation any reasonable viewer
arrive with an appropriate amount of
skepticism about the statements that he
makes this is
his own lawyers making this argument
yeah but it's about i know
but it's a bad faith argument because
any reasonable viewer would
does not make that conclusion no
reasonable viewer watches his [ __ ]
show
got him it's not even a joke
well there is a lot of people that watch
his show sadly there's a lot of old
people that watch the show and they
don't know they're being lied to and
their brain fill up with [ __ ] poison
they go oh and then they just walk
around saying this [ __ ] like oh he was
high he the fentanyl killed him the
fentanyl killed him
so you know okay
the um the defense
brought a medical expert
that was trying to say all this stuff
about the fentanyl and the co2 and all
the [ __ ] that could have killed him
so the prosecution under cross
examination destroys this guy
okay watch this this goes to candace
owens state this blatant [ __ ] lie at
fox news that he was so high on
fentanyl he was on the verge of an
overdose three times
three times he's first put on the ground
that he's pulled out of the car
squad 320 he's subdued and restrained on
the ground
mr chavin is on his uh neck and back
um did you ever see mr floyd
at any time uh manifest
either sleepiness a lack of awareness
that he wasn't arousable and that sort
of thing
no not until you lost consciousness and
and typically doctor when somebody
uh passes away from a fentanyl or opioid
overdose
one of the hallmarks of that is that
they are
very sleepy and they will tend to be
unarousable
and uh pass away in essentially a coma
right correct if they are passing away
from fentanyl overdose
that's what happens and mr floyd was
manifesting none of those
outward symptoms was he correct it does
not
exclude the fact that it was still
having a depressive effect on his
respiratory system well before he lost
consciousness
uh his respiration rate i think you told
us uh that you agree with dr tobin
was somewhere in the ballpark of 22
breaths a minute right
correct that is normal isn't it
yes if fentanyl was affecting his
respiration
then you would expect it a respiratory
rate that would have been appreciably
less than 22 breaths a minute
if it's depressing his uh respiratory
system
right unless he should have been
breathing at 30 at that particular stage
because of his exertion and other
stressors
and you have no really basis or baseline
to suggest that mr floyd should have
been breathing at 30
instead of normal 22 right a person who
is getting short of oxygen to their
brain
will often increase or usually increase
their respiratory rate to more than 30.
i wonder why he was getting a shortage
of oxygen to his brain
maybe it was the knee in his neck
chauvin's taking note he was writing the
whole time
which is just like what the [ __ ] are you
writing dude
he's like right i'm [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
anyways i think that was the relevant
part there was a part where he's talking
about dosage
in the blood work done in the autopsy
there was 11 nanograms of fentanyl
present
and according to expert witnesses this
is not
enough to be considered fatal as you can
see he clearly wasn't
having depression of breathing he wasn't
in a coma he wasn't showing any signs of
com
of an overdose you know um
there were two autopsies done one by a
county medical examiner
and another by private medical examiner
hired by
floyd's family as well as a review by
military experts
and they all conducted they all
concluded the same thing that floyd died
of culminary polio culminary
cardiopulmonary arrest
as the officer subdued him and
compressed his neck and chest
on the [ __ ] birth or on the death
certificate it all says homicide
says homicide he was murdered this claim
that he has three times the luthier dose
is some boomer meme
from facebook this is the only origin of
this claim
that we can find so apparently candace
is just on boomer facebook
here's the post george floyd had enough
fentanyl in his system to kill three
grown men or two stacey abrams
nice attack a completely irrelevant
attack on stacey abrams
like why did you have to even do that
but no i mean no he did not have enough
to even overdose
one normal human being so again this is
all literal [ __ ] lies and propaganda
the fact that they're even able to
broadcast such a blatant [ __ ] lie
is uh honestly
honestly bro i don't think i don't think
they should be able to do that
if they're news they gotta there needs
to be a standard
you know this this is just this or they
need to make it more clear that they're
not the news
yeah i would like to see a disclaimer in
front of carl's show every time where he
goes
hi this is just a performance anything i
say should not be taken seriously
even that's not enough but yeah i mean
what the [ __ ] it's just a blatant lie
more carl carl tucken is on suicide
watch from this verdict
carl tucken to carl duncan that's his
name god damn it he's carl tucker now
dude doesn't i i should deserve the
respect of his name
here's carl tucken having a meltdown i
just think
when he has one reasonable dude on the
show that agrees with the verdict
tucker has an absolute [ __ ] meltdown
by the way is a is a
former police officer oh he's like oh
well [ __ ] you you need to resign yeah
he's just he's not hardcore enough
yeah all police need to resign are you
resigning
we want our freedom for the world trader
this trader isn't even making an
ish issuing a statement calling on every
police officer to resign i think that
it was excessive and it shouldn't happen
and what i'd like to do the guy who did
it looks like he's going to spend the
rest of his life in prison so
i'm kind of more worried about the rest
of the country which thanks to police
inaction in case you haven't noticed
is like boarded up so that's more of my
concern
bro he's literally having a meltdown i
don't even know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about
he says police in action the rest of the
country is being boarded up he's just
talking about riots that aren't taking
place
what's he talking about is he making
sense
no that's joker brain exactly that is a
[ __ ]
meant psychic break we should sound bite
that laugh
yeah i'll pull it it's police in action
in case you haven't noticed is like
boarded up
so that's more of my concern but i
appreciate it thank you hello
nope done thank you wow i i just think
that
what a [ __ ] legend
yeah full meltdown because
uh one officer was held accountable you
know they act like the whole our whole
gov our whole democracy is falling apart
because one officer who clearly murdered
someone on tape
is going to jail god [ __ ] forbid
that's funny man that's chet chet has
the best joker laugh
did you guys know that you can't say
chet hanks without ethan in the middle
i kind of blew my mind when i someone
posted that on the subreddit
chet hanks has ethan in the middle
take for that what you will ferment
oh greg gutfield this was a great one
uh even getting reprimanded by his own
co-host on fox news for the absolutely
vile take
and now i'm going to just get really
selfish uh i'm glad
that he was found guilty on all charges
yeah even
if he might not be guilty of all charges
i am glad that he is guilty of all
charges
because i want a verdict that keeps this
country from going up in flames
uh uh-uh oh my goodness no outrage right
even is unclear what do you mean
dumb ass cause oh i didn't realize
that's the woman i was talking about
right there yeah so i mean she's usually
real far right well but uh
yeah let her finish he's being honest uh
my my tat my neighborhood
was looted i don't ever want to go
through that again we do not
sacrifice individuals for the sake
i'm saying he's guilty i'm saying i'm
glad about the verdict
shut up dude this guy's such a piece of
[ __ ] he literally is just
taking the shittiest take possible he
goes okay
i don't believe he's guilty but i'm
happy he's being
found guilty because my neighborhood's
not gonna get burned down like
okay bro can you find a shittier take
oh my god now i gotta tell you i heard
uh
greg a few minutes ago and i got to tell
you i don't know greg
uh is off his meds he believes excuse me
there was not ever you heard him what
did you say
he said you're off your meds you
sensitive little [ __ ]
this is very you're getting so outraged
because he said you're off your meds
what about a cop just killed somebody
more outraged about this little s what
did you say
excuse me what did he say
yes that's what
these guys are such [ __ ] they say the
most [ __ ] up thing they tipped
they veil it like in the slightest veil
and so they can just be like i didn't
say that
you said i'm glad he's going to jail
even if he's not guilty
so why would you say that
why would you say that unless you don't
think that he might not be guilty
let me tell you this this
judge could as janine said conducted
a fair hearing
i'm not you said
it's like coward tommy laren
another piece of [ __ ] you know
the usual suspects she i love this she
goes you
got your justice what you got your
justice so i'm assuming there will be
peace in minneapolis tonight no writing
no looting no harassing officers
well there wasn't right dan
not that i heard of yeah i didn't hear
of any writing
uh she walked this back real quick by
the way she
she did say that she she thought he was
guilty
i don't know if she was sincere she was
just saying that because she got a lot
of flack
but yeah well that's what the guy in fox
news hey i didn't say he was not guilty
right but i love this she goes you got
your justice i'm sorry who got
who's justice why is it your again this
is like the otherism it's like hey black
people you got your justice that's what
you're saying she's saying yeah okay
black people you got your justice so now
you're gonna do the right thing right
[ __ ] it's everybody's justice i love
the top reply
what's this shut up [ __ ]
shut up uh that clip's awesome we should
sound like that
yeah that's a good one you got it
yeah you okay black people you got your
justice excuse me justice is justice
that's not your justice it's not our
justice you [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] [ __ ] you such a horrible person
literally how does it feel just to
[ __ ] sell your soul
for clicks
damn crazy these people are
insane oh another one i know this is
going on long guys but i'm sorry i just
i really enjoy this
these people are having meltdowns and i
feel like we should celebrate this
well it's such a mask off moment for
these people you know
she says is foot locker safe tonight
black store
right should it should be right justice
right
no need to steal the name of george
fulleriem all right again
no writing you [ __ ] racist piece of
[ __ ]
there was no writing again you're
literally just calling out black people
who got there i mean uh you know mask
off
these you can see them for what they are
now
timothy burke who's this oh yeah of
course
and of course not to leave out
the left side as well this blew my mind
uh nancy pelosi made a really bizarre
statement
in response to the guilty verdict thank
you george floyd
for sacrificing your life for justice
she says thank you george floyd for
sacrificing your life for jesus
i don't think he sacrificed his life i
think he was murdered i don't i think if
he could choose he probably choose to be
alive
yes it was not a choice you're [ __ ]
idiot he's not a
did man you know what i mean he didn't
jump on a grenade he was murdered
that reminds me of something dave
chappelle said in terms of people trying
to assassinate his characters that we
didn't choose him you chose him
right you chose him because he was
killed and it wasn't right
so right that's a good point yeah i
remember when dave made that point it's
really good
it's like we didn't choose for this guy
to be the [ __ ]
hero the hero of the movement you're the
one that [ __ ] murdered him
yeah exactly but a lot of people were
making a comparison to zach go ahead
what this sounds like someone else we
know
go ahead zach what are you talking about
you know what i'm talking about
don't make me don't make me say it
who nancy sounds like that you
come on i'm not following either yeah
me me three sorry oh okay i guess it's
me
shout out to your family oh
he's sounding a lot like uh
yeah he's doing a shout out to his
family david
yeah david
yeah i mean obviously this is another
this is a completely different kind of
um tone deafness
from all the other ones that we watch
but but it is still tone definitely
she's tone that if she made a
she made a goof she's just like she
missed you the point right
right she's not a [ __ ] like you can't
compare it to these other [ __ ] bags
they're just overtly racist
yeah it's not i'm not trying to make a
false equivalency but
for being there to call out to your mom
i mean she's
it's just funny it's just it's just
funny it's like shout out to the family
yeah exactly
i really think that the world needs to
have peace
and i want to say i dedicate this song
to george ford's family
and i hope this shout out comforts them
during this dark time that's it that's
all i have about this
should we watch david gouda just to do a
little eye bleach
sure david giudice cures
fixes racism david david gouda
i already got it
[Music]
all right guys let's let's end racism
here now
like nancy pelosi and i really hope we
can see more
unity and more peace when already things
are so difficult
so difficult so shout out to his family
[Music]
yes shout out to the family
oh can i get a whomp bump for the family
can i get a yeah
[Music]
oh man it's been exhausting
what do you think i mean am i
overreacting i mean what do you think
about all these conservative
three free thinkers that are having
meltdowns might
what's your take it's just
i think that they really thought he was
gonna get off
um and you can see it based off of you
know all of their statements
uh leading up to it and then even some
of the statements after the fact
that they they had already kind of
established this narrative that he's
going to walk
and the the country is going to burn
down
in is going to be rise because the black
people are
can't control themselves and they didn't
they didn't so
they had this all kind of built up in
their head
and then it went the other way and
kind of like shoving himself i think
there's just a degree of shock
and that's why i mean these takes were
still coming out from some of these
people of
like uh okay no riots now or or just all
of this and
you know they're still talking about the
riots which aren't happening yeah they
had the whole fantasy they had their
whole week of content lined up
right around riot exactly and so hey by
the way you know what causes riots
and theft and stuff like that
desperation and poverty [ __ ] face
how about a little [ __ ] compassion
yeah in the face of
justice system which is not delivering
on
on justice you know what you can't
imagine yourself going to foot locker
and stealing shoes it's because you're
not [ __ ] poor and desperate
not justifying what they're doing but
i'm saying there's like there's cause
there's cause and reasons for everything
exactly
you know dan's a good man thank you
thank you joe
you said that with a lot of conviction
he really believes that yeah
he's good at that we love dan
oh who is that i believe that was wendy
williams andy williams
oh thanks wendy wow a lot of love for
dan and they're about to stay
you guys watch the jake paul boxing boy
did i ever bro i l i saw this joke on
lines but so i'm not going to claim this
as my own but it is what comes to mind
i [ __ ] pirated that [ __ ] and i still
felt robbed
like man i watched that whole [ __ ]
thing it was supposed to start
at like six and then there's like all
these there's like doji cat and justin
bieber i was like what the [ __ ] is going
on
the concert aspect of it was
mind-blowing i can't like
it's crazy
high-level people yeah yeah totally but
i don't think there's a big crossover of
people that want to watch
boxing and people that want to watch
justin bieber
so i don't know not really right right
exactly
but anyway the the [ __ ] fight here's
the knockout
i'll show you guys so i waited all night
for this [ __ ] fight and then you know
i
you guys gave me so much [ __ ] when i was
saying that ben askrem didn't look good
um did i show the picture of his
weigh-in i don't think i ever showed
that you guys
maybe we did on after dark i forget i
don't think i did
yeah can you guys no i don't really uh
i was a little baffled by the um by all
the mma people
fans coming after you because you
everything that you said ended up being
100
i was like look he's out of shape he's
retired he's not a boxer
this is not a fair fight jake is way
bigger i mean look yeah he's an olympian
he was
but i mean he's not a boxer he doesn't
know how to box and he's out of shape he
hasn't fought
i mean here's his weigh-in photo the
dude is built like me
the guy has no definition the guy he's
out of shape
unquestionably i mean come on what kind
of weigh-in is this bro [ __ ] fried
chicken
this is a prized fighter and what world
is a surprise fighter headlining
this was the to be fair he always kind
of looked like this because i i
after the fact went and looked at some
footage of he did not look like this
pull-up i mean not as flabby but if you
see any pictures of him from
his uh mma days in the ufc he he doesn't
look like a typical
mma fighter because he comes from
wrestling he was always a
you know dude he's got listen he was
definitely more jacked but
yeah yeah but that's way better i mean
look how jacked his arms are
i i agree but okay look at him next to
any other
ufc fight look at this right okay okay
yes obviously he's okay he's lost a step
and look at this okay he's jacked look
at his arms
you know i agree look at this
look at this yeah ben asked her ladies
and gentlemen
i'm not taking anything away from him in
his previous life but this is a [ __ ]
j this matchup is a joke
i'm so over this youtube boxing [ __ ]
unless he fights a real [ __ ]
boxer in the prime of his career next
time i am not i'm we're not watching i
don't want any more [ __ ] fights from
jake
he literally just knocked out a 40 year
old man who hasn't fought in like a
two like several years who has no
experience in boxing
we don't care although even considering
all that
i was still first of all they fought for
like what a few minutes on the top of
the hill
like a minute and a half and
you know and you know
he just get he didn't even block the
punch and he just
the whole thing looks like a comic book
like look how he falls to the ground
it's like
you know and then the ref calls it
immediately i was like dude what did i
just watch
what is this is such a [ __ ] clown
fest
look at this and then he calls it i was
like no i seriously did not
stay up and waste my whole saturday
night to not even
see jake paul get hit once
i don't know why that riff called it bro
i know he was dazed he was [ __ ]
the fight was a joke in that moment
right there if you watch it
carefully he tells him to step forward
and he staggers to the side
yeah i i i mean he's it looked at first
i was like what was that everyone was
saying it's staged
i don't think so i looked at everything
from every angle
well he for sure got the i mean it can
be staged with still taking a hit
that it was just planned that he would
get punched i still think the ref should
have let him go like i mean it's a prize
fight
okay like [ __ ] like who is this ref get
a different ref you tell him let the
fight go man
ben askren's taking beatings in the mma
dude he's not gonna
jake paul's not gonna kill ben askren
don't worry about it
you're tripping it was just it was the
worst
fight it was such a waste and then jake
paul literally
fell to the floor in a fetal position
balling his eyes out in happiness
yeah there were some good memes so like
when you when you knock out a
four-year-old
at a shape wrestler
although i don't apparently he had a
friend who died and i don't know what it
was it was more about
uh perhaps but anyway here's here he is
i mean
you know he probably watched rocky four
before the fight
i mean everything he does is like
everything he does he's just trying to
imitate conor
mcgregor's just you know what's crazy
though i gotta say
these paul brothers are like [ __ ] uh
her genital herpes man they do not go
away
you know this was the 10th here let me
see
um 10th highest
you have that info chart did you guys
find that
let me see that this was the freaking
most
pay-per-view ordered event in history
which is absolutely insane 1.5 million
pay-per-view orders
i didn't pay for that [ __ ]
i almost did but ann came through with
the link daddy
i don't know what you're talking about
uh you play cool
you didn't do anything wrong i didn't do
anything and you said
you had like backups on backups and
backups i was like this one's not
working i'm going to buy it you're like
hold strong
you send me one that works that's me
guys somebody
i don't know what i'm doing i'm looking
for right now in our chat
um i gotta hand to these guys they're
hustlers man
it's crazy that these guys won't [ __ ]
just get out of my life
and i can't help it i'm curious i want
to watch this fight
you know but i was so
pissed about the way that fight went
that
unless he's fighting a boxer in his
prime i just can't watch it so check
this out
here's the top 10 pay-per-view events of
all time
why does it say 110 because it's tied
oh i see tied for 10. yep
yeah it's right up there it's kind of
interesting to look at
floyd versus manny pacquiao was number
one
jesus that was an awful fight too i
didn't realize that was fight was like
that big of a deal
it's crazy to see like you know mike
tyson's big fights his
big fights mike tyson versus lennox
lewis
1.9 million mike tyson vs roy jones jr
1.6 he's right there that's
do you guys understand how crazy that is
yeah it's pretty wild
jake fought uh before mike during that
fight
that's when he uh knocked out um say
what robin
jake fought in that card too he was a
part of that fight
the mike tyson fight the one you just
described
[Music]
he was an undercard mike tyson looked
good
yeah i would like to see mike tyson
fight jake paul
me too that'd be [ __ ] now that's a
pay-per-view event i paid for that i
wouldn't even buy with that i would just
pay for that you know
it would be too good man oh my god a 65
year old mike tyson he beat the [ __ ] out
of him wouldn't he
it's i mean my my impulse is to say yeah
of course he's
65. yeah the age difference is is absurd
so
he's pretty certainly no but i mean
obviously he's still in great shape and
he looked good in that fight he's pretty
yolked man
yeah i don't know so anyway i don't know
they made a [ __ ] apparently they
generated 65 million
dollars to fight they must have spent a
lot on performances they had like all
these huge artists yeah
you know usually we're trying to figure
out how much jake made
because the official earnings
has paul's fight salary at seven hundred
thousand
and ascrines five hundred thousand but
these kind of big price fights you get
usually
a split of the pay-per-view revenue
right
yeah so
which seems to vary wildly depending on
your
size and how big it's expected to be and
everything
this is a really weird case because it
was really big but like not for the
reasons
that traditionally they would be big so
if you look at mayweather and mcgregor
fight which
sold like over four million that was
like the biggest price fight ever those
guys split forty percent of the people
of the pay-per-view revenue which is
insane i mean that's why they they each
made like hundreds of millions of
dollars from that fight it was
absolutely bonkers
yeah but my hunch if i'm just gonna take
a guess here
is that jake paul probably got
between
definitely not more than ten percent i
think he got like five percent
he also has equity in triller so that's
what
that's interesting that is the aspect
that makes me think it might be a little
bit higher actually
because what why no they would because
they have to pay him less
they would be like no you're doing it
for the company that's why
you're doing it you know they i don't
think he got more i think he got less
okay it's just not he's not he knows
everybody knows he's not conor mcgregor
he's not mayweather these these are this
is just a circus they're trying to make
a reputation for themselves that's where
they're spending all this money on
performances and [ __ ] trying to get
something more interesting yeah
i think he got like between five and ten
percent so that's between you know
if he said it was 65 million dollars
generated so
that's between like three and six
million bucks
not bad not bad i mean i gotta say i'm
impressed with the hustle these guys
always figure out how to make a [ __ ]
buck man it's kind of insane these guys
used to sling merch like it was damn
crack to these kids and now they're
selling boxing tickets i don't know man
um that being said i want to watch him i
will have no respect for him as a
fighter until he fights a real boxer
period and that is oh man
nah you're tripping
you're tripping oh we have to talk about
the frank media [ __ ] okay
frank oh brother
so the my pillow guy
dan you want to you want to explain this
you've been you're the one that's been
following this whole
you've been spending a lot of time oh
i've been following i love
dan good luck i love mike lindell um
he has brought a lot of joy to me over
the last couple months with his
buffoonery um he's i was saying to the
guys the other day i really think he's
he's going for the crown from rudy like
the biggest goon
the biggest goon i mean rudy had a hell
of a run a few months ago if you all
recall with him
uh bleeding uh squid ink from his
forehead
and doing a press conference in front of
a dildo shop
i think frank i think mike liddell the
fact that he's
burning probably like hundreds of
millions of dollars is kind of
epic right rudy was getting
somehow paid for all of his antics so
that is um
i don't know if that redeems him a
little bit
in some ways sexual dance anyway so mike
lindell
mike lindell after being banned from uh
pretty much all social media for
his uh election fraud claims has decided
to launch
his own social media site um called
frank frank
speech which is all about free speech
except god
except you can't take the lord's name in
vain you can't say the f word
the cornerstone of all free speech
exceptions no cursing
god right no and no f word no
c word and no n word which i think
probably lost him a sizable chunk of his
potential audience no and we're not [ __ ]
that i'll stay on twitter
right so yo can you when he says the f
word is he talking about like
about gay people or is he talking about
like oh i just assumed it was sanity
i just assumed it was [ __ ] but i assumed
it was [ __ ] too that's that
yeah i mean that's that's the f word
yeah let's be real
once when somebody says the effort so
anyways um so he was really hyping this
up that it was going to be the next big
thing it was going to be like uh better
than
all these other kind of spin-off social
media networks like um
what is it parlor and gab
this is michael by the way you guys do
others yeah it's just a reminder for
anybody that
the mypillow guy who's on your tv thanks
to your support you've helped make my
pillow become one of the fastest growing
companies in america
over the last 12 years you've held my
pillow created this whole my pillow
phenomenon just blows my mind
those pillows suck awful products yeah
zach uh famously uh got one and
didn't give it very good reviews but
yeah so um
i signed up because i was curious and i
am a free speech warrior i'm all about
free speech everybody knows that
and um so i i signed up with uh with
my phone number to get vip access here's
the home page supposed to launch
how's this looking yeah so right away
there were issues
as you can see their site was all kinds
of [ __ ] up it kept going up and down
sometimes just nothing would be on there
sometimes you get
this just bad gateway bad gateway baby
real quick start interrupt i um like dan
i
i mistakenly gave them my real phone
number
yeah that's that wasn't a good idea so
i've been getting all these spam calls
recently
like since i signed up i [ __ ] you not
like i can show you these numbers
i mean you're selling your your data
straight up it could be or they just got
hacked like immediately which was my
thought because
that happened with parlor and um
there was a parlor of gab i forget but
these these conservative
apparently conservatives don't know how
to build a website like that's just
a common theme well they think you can
make it in a week this guy made this
website in a week
yeah and so the website is now down it
says thank you for visiting frank
with over 2 billion requests
yeah 2 billion
that's like that's like 8 times the
population of america
in just two days the frank speech
experiment experiment
is a massive success it's interesting
that they refer to it as an experiment
because it was
not an experiment at any point
in the lead-up to it so we've
retroactively declared it
an experiment um and that may be because
uh
it was described as a social media
platform
but during the time that it was up
during this experiment um
it just appeared to be a platform for
him
to do an alex jones kind of cosplay
okay so when you go on the website
all there was was a video of mike live
having a meltdown
there was no social media aspect
there was no [ __ ] there was no social
media it was just a new
like a yeah it was a news weird infowars
style
here's a website here's a clip of mike
well thank you
thank you hey hold on i got i think i
got a reporter beaming in scott thank
you for calling and god bless the
lighting is great
hello this is his show hey mike it's
wrong with the wall street journal
yes yes you're live is that okay
oh yeah that's great but mike i have
some bad news to tell you i'm afraid and
i wish
i hope you can share this with everybody
but unfortunately alexa passed away just
a few minutes ago from a drug overdose
okay that's uh this is a prank call this
is a prank phone call
you see what they're doing everybody
let's see what they're doing everybody
that was an attack there because i
brought up this great reporter
he keeps getting pranked all day on his
weird bizarro he's still talking about
election fraud
he's tr he's got excel graphs up like
charlie from always sunny you know that
concern that's literally him
looking at charts about like big massive
voting dumps
here he thought trump trump was he
actually thought trump was calling into
his show it was just a prank caller like
what
full screen breaking news here with a
guest hello
hello yes i have mr trump on standby are
you ready
yes go ahead sir
[Music]
hello everyone oh we have the president
here our real president
everyone hello mr president
macron dot com pictures
okay all right i guess that would you
see what they're doing
this is what his social media platform
is it's just this but uh
i mean that even came up there he was
hacking into our phones that came up
that it was the legitimacy a legitimate
i know the numbers coming from
from you know and he was live for like
48 hours so he was just
as descending into madness basically
losing his mind
absolutely and uh fantastic
yeah um we actually i i managed to find
who did the prank phone call i found a
video of of the other side of it
uh here it is just some random youtuber
and uh you got any questions here oh
well you know i'm doctor
ray i'm calling in can you say i have mr
trump on standby
just that okay right you ready
yeah yeah yeah it's just ringing here
all right so we've got
i think we gotta hello
hello yes i have mr trump on standby are
you ready
yes yes go ahead sir
hello everyone well we have the
president
here our real president everyone hello
mr president
macron show.com bitchesmacronshow.com we
own you you [ __ ] crackhead
michael dell macro.com to smoke crack so
everybody gives on him for that
listen i used to i smoked crack once i
admit it he's so embarrassed just own it
you're a crackhead or used to be a
crackhead
reformed crackhead oh man
i just love that they weren't even
screening like you could hear from
he was he was taking phone calls on his
goddamn yeah
on his personal personal phone oh my god
it's just so [ __ ] good enough
well thank you thank you hey hold on i
got i think i got it
this is the one we uh already watched
yeah yeah um
so yeah it it was a bit of a
it was a bit of a disaster the the frank
experiment uh here okay
so you're not at all discouraged by the
the platform still not being up
and also wait wait wait what do you what
do you mean the platform not being up
it's been up all day
and people are on there what are you
talking about did you not hear
we let people on by their phone numbers
in the order they were received
people that signed up early we let them
on they're already on there just because
maybe you didn't put your phone number
in
any users are still not onto the
platform who told you that
what are you talking about there every
90 million people got on here today 90
minutes
your garbage we're done talking you see
people what we have to put up with
that they see this guy's trying to say
this was a failure there's no
disappointment
this was the best day for america this
was what is it today the patriot group
this is the patriot day and you know
what the shot heard around the world
this will be heard around the world you
just you know what no one's going to
bother and read your rubbish anymore
because they're all going to be going to
frank where all the great reporters are
coming
where you know what you better what
happened if
man i i can't i can't i seriously can't
it's a big
massive dump it's crazy um
it's such a disaster it's such a
disaster
i've been loving it i was just that and
i was checking in every morning
seeing what's going on frank and then
finally it's over
he's like he's had enough it's done two
billion requests
it was 90 million in that last clip plan
it yeah
right bye bye
anyway mike meanwhile mike liddell who's
actually started smoking crack again
clearly
is being sued by dominion for 1.3
billion dollars for defamation
he with rudyard giuliani fox news sydney
powell
are being sued for saying that dominion
they were saying all this crazy [ __ ]
that dominion is owned by
argentina and it's no uh venezuela
venezuela maduro it was used to change
the
[ __ ] voting you know and and dominion
is like the super legit
i watched uh 60 minutes about it really
good they're like a super legit company
that does
voting um security for a bunch of
countries
and uh they're like yeah they're they
ruined our business with these lies
there's no evidence and we have to sue
them for 1.3 billion dollars because
this
is pretty much ruined yeah so
like you said mike lindell doing the
bankruptcy speed run
definitely i think he's got a good shot
to be honest
i mean he i think he's gonna hold the
title yeah i mean last i looked before
he started getting into all this
insanity uh his net worth was in the
hundreds of millions
just selling pillows man just [ __ ]
pillow money
laying in those pillows dude mike
lindell
net worth estimated at 300 million
yeah it's a a lot less than that now i
bet
a lot less than that well he got dropped
from all the like big box retailers
that probably hurt now he's getting sued
for 1.3
billy and he's turned himself into a
meme i mean i i i'm sure
to an extent he's made up some of those
sales from all the die hard
how many white supremacists are how many
uh how many you know
that actually need a bigger market yeah
it's not the uh biggest demographic
thankfully
god knows how much he's smoking on crack
he was relentlessly
promoting uh his pillow on this
live stream by the way though with a
code
use code mypillow go to mypillow.com and
use code mypillow
please please buy a pillow anyway
this is the political episode a little
bit
not political it's goofs these people
are outrageous
anyway that's all i've got this is this
episode is just
you don't have to watch this episode if
you don't like it you know what i mean
i don't know what to tell you we
this is all the [ __ ] i wanted to talk
about you know
we're off the rails baby that's right
so that's the show it's off the rails if
you like it come if you don't don't
there's two other episodes every week
that are good
and this one's off the rails
i don't know when i like when i listen
to howard stern which is like the only
show
kind of like this that i follow i
personally
love when he talks about this kind of
stuff in politics because i find it
refreshing
to hear his opinion about stuff
and um so i don't know for me i i i like
it but i know some people don't like it
so that it that's
it is what it is you don't have to like
it this is my wednesday show it's my
show
i deserve to talk about fried chicken
i deserve to talk about derek chovin
[ __ ] wednesday [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's wednesday off the rails baby
with ethan it's my show
[ __ ] fried chicken [ __ ] yeah it's my
show
baby yeah wednesday it's ethan's show
thank you
i deserve wednesdays it's my show
yeah fried chicken wednesday yeah baby
baby
wednesday's ethan show baby i deserve
ethan show baby [ __ ] fried chicken
he's blowing up man white claw gabe
how long until the white claw gabe
scandal he gets the name
for talking about how long don't even
say that how dare you yeah
[ __ ] one of my favorite nights
[ __ ] is one of my favorite nights
wednesday baby ethan show
you know speaking of getting exposed
this guy eat eat that [ __ ] 4 4 5.
he's like so off the rails man he even
came on our show once a while ago
bro another one bites this guy got
exposed by some like pedo hunters
for flirting with like a 13 year old
it's a whole [ __ ] red-handed
what is wrong with people i don't know i
mean the problem the edp
like
here let me who could have predicted the
guy named eat that [ __ ]
445 would be a creep
well the problem is with someone like
that is everyone knows he's a creep
so well in the video they they put out
uh which i think they just put out he
describes why his name is edp 445.
what does he say he says that his
original logo was a pacman
eating a cat so that's why he got eat
that [ __ ] 445
really yeah that was his explanation for
it
that's interesting less graphic than i
expected fascinating
oh here it is bro 84 messages yeah here
he is getting caught red-handed
and you know edp is not someone that has
like big brand affiliations and stuff
like james charles
so and like celebrity endorsements and
[ __ ] there's a really interesting
article written by
i think the new york times that girl um
i forget her name but she said that
people
in mainstream media are laundering the
images of these
you know criminals predators
and trolls because they don't know
enough about the internet so you take
someone like james charles and then you
put him with all these celebrities and
you popularize him they're laundering
his image
to make him palatable because they don't
they they just don't know better
even though he's doing all this heinous
[ __ ] and
i'm not physically attracted to older
guys but the anyway someone like edp his
image is not being laundered is my point
so you know
everyone should know he's a [ __ ]
predator and it's being talked about a
lot but god it's it's so gross
84 messages okay so
we have you talking to sophie correct
yes or no
right okay sophie is how old before and
again i have it right here i know the
answer but i just need you to tell me
the answer how old is she
13 13. okay and before we get into the
messages
there was sexual content involved yes or
no right
and you said correct okay all right
so again so what brings you out here he
sent an
older picture of his dick
there's so many predators online amongst
youtubers desperate
he's at like a school he's like on a
school campus he's really being a third
year old school campus
what the [ __ ] i didn't even realize
i mean that's definitely a school right
look i don't know a hundred percent
it looks
apartment apartment building where she
said she was home alone
i was going to say it kind of looks like
it could be just bungalow
and his reason for going was you just
wanted to get a cupcake from her
oh wow that's believable why'd you send
a picture of your dick though
you just want to get a cupcake what it's
awesome
nah i've saw the dms he's totally [ __ ]
there's this dmv of the girl being like
i'm on i'm is that okay he's like yeah i
don't give a [ __ ]
okay well there you go yeah there's no
there's no way around this one for edp
so is he gonna go to prison
like how do they handle this well i i
imagine because they're like that's
their thing they're pedo hunters so this
is like chris hansen [ __ ]
yeah i mean i imagine they're gonna hand
it over to the authorities
i would yeah i bet you the police don't
do [ __ ] i don't care
lazy [ __ ] i like to make love
here today um whoa how was uh
coming out here glasses off okay
oh i was actually coming out here to
pick up a cupcake
and then go back home um you know it's
funny to see him like this because he's
usually
all like he's got all this attitude and
um
yeah abby says there's no reports about
his arrest i don't think he's gonna get
arrested i really don't it's like you
give this to the police
they're like what is this [ __ ] who is
this person they don't they're a bunch
of [ __ ] old ass boomers
i swear to god i'm not saying all police
but you know a lot of them are
they're not going to rest to mark my
words
mark them right now i will mark your
words
and i will throw them in your face
nobody's getting arrested for anything
you can do anything on youtube and you
will not face any legal consequences if
there was any justice in the world james
shaw would already be in a jail cell
what edp ain't [ __ ] well it is [ __ ]
it's not the predator olympics
[Music]
um but eddie's bitten he's going there
me uh
yeah i don't know man doesn't think he
might be in trouble
and he's been caught before right he got
caught before getting titty pics from
from a young girl yikes yeah
don't talk to uh youtubers
people if you're out there honestly
that's a good general rule
just don't even talk as youtubers take
it from us do not do not contact us
i never talk to a fan i don't even look
at my instagram dms bro i've never
looked in that [ __ ] that [ __ ] is trouble
i don't even never even looked in that
and
unsolicited dms i don't even ever look
at that [ __ ] dude
i am desperate i was a fan but you never
sent me a dick pic
well i didn't i don't know what the hell
dms
yeah i know you made a video and i think
i
tweeted you or something yeah you
entered one of my live streams one night
or something
slid into the live stream huh split into
the end of that line never did i ever
ask for a picture of your dick
i don't also how old are you i could ask
for a picture of your dick just say no
it's an ownership that's an abuse of the
power dynamic ethan
he's a fan he's a simp yeah if i said
give me show me one picture of your dick
and then you get the job would you do it
that's a lawsuit man
back then i don't know maybe oh
i could have got a picture of your dick
i under leveraged myself
yeah messed up man s-i-m-p
all right we've uh we've hit our time
limit here oh for real
yes [ __ ] wait i really want to watch
this um just here because edp
when he does his videos he's always like
he's like all charged up and confident
and now it's
it's just odd to see him like all scared
and exposed
beta and [ __ ] you know nothing
that was going to be sexual involved
because i'm not like that you know well
obviously the text messages and stuff
like that
um so yeah that was all that was going
to happen
oh okay so you should title a video
instead of you know your video
almost through hands with a 13 year old
you should title your video almost
with a 13 year old i think that'll get a
lot of hits edp i think so
yeah so so this is you texting all this
correct this is your instagram yes or no
right
okay all right so again what made you
what made you what made you start this
conversation with this
said 13 year old you said what you're
doing right here correct yes or no all
right okay go ahead anyway
oh boy that's
you know i'm glad he got exposed for
sure because obviously
he is extremely disturbing but um
just like with the chris hanson stuff i
just i don't know
how i feel about making content out of
this confrontation well i've always been
very uneasy about the whole chris hanson
the catcher better thing it's just just
give it to the police it's not
it's just condoms i don't like it yeah i
don't like it either
it's just and the guy is like totally
doing like a wannabe cop shtick and it's
just
i don't know it's just well chris hansen
does have police lined up
so like whenever they walk outside there
i know but but that's not his primary
goal his primary goal is to make a
television show
right you can set up a sting without
[ __ ] cameras and [ __ ]
and then you got all these vigilantes
out here to me
i mean in this case i think this is this
is so cut and dry like
it's fine i don't want to be overly
critical of what they did like
it's good that they're exposing this guy
so i'm not familiar with these guys i
don't know anything about them
but i i've always had that unease about
what chris hansen does i i totally
get what you're saying i mean look edp
that's [ __ ] gross
uh he should go to jail i mean has
there's been a lot of these scandals
that i don't know if there's any
as cut and dry as this one though my god
like
no and he's not even denying it well
james charles is cut and dry i mean
he flirted with [ __ ] miners fixed it
with miners
true although this is pretty [ __ ] cut
and dry too
god that's disgusting do you want to get
a cupcake bruh
it also just seems dangerous for them to
be confronting like
you know nothing happened here but if
this is their like whole thing
i don't know when people are
caught like that you know they might
freak out i mean their life
is is being ruined in that moment and
you know
i don't know it seems a little sketch to
meet
uh somebody like that in a parking lot
somewhere so
you're worried for this i think a little
bit i think they're fun i mean in this
case yes but like
i've watched enough to catch a predator
it's always like some sad pathetic dude
who's just like
i mean they have a bunch of people there
they probably have weapons too
i'd like a [ __ ] to see a shootout [ __ ]
it but that's what i mean it's like now
you're
you're going aunties for the internet
right you're going into a parking lot to
meet with a predator with a gun in your
pocket
let's go like this
it was an old to catch a predator but
the guy actually brought his son
oh don't stop terrible
all right we've really gotta make it
back we gotta
wrap it up all right
thanks for watching everybody this has
been off the rails see you on friday for
a show that you will definitely enjoy
see then and for those reasons i'm out
thanks mark cuban
didn't ask